>> SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT WILL BEGIN.
AND WE ARE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY.
I SEE SOME OF THE MEMBERS ARE
HERE,
AND WE WILL START OUT OF FILE
ORDER WITH ITEM NUMBER 13 AB
2975 ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2975.
I WANT TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE THE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO STRENGTHENING, UM,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2975.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A VERY
COMMON SENSE BILL ABOUT, UM,
PROTECTING OUR HOSPITAL,
MAKING SURE THAT OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS,
AS WELL AS OUR PATIENTS,
WHO'S GOING TO THESE HOSPITALS,
HAVE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
AND SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
IMPROVE THE HOSPITAL
SAFETY BY REQUIRING WEAPONS
DETECTING
SCREENINGS AT SELECTED HOSPITAL
ENTRANCES
CONDUCTED BY TRAINED PERSONNEL.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE FIVE
TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO SUFFER WORKPLACE INJURIES
OR VIOLENCE,
AND WORKERS THAN WORKERS
OVERALL,
AND VIOLENCE IS TRENDING UPWARD
IN OUR HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
THIS BILL, ASSEMBLY BILL 2975,
PROPOSES TO ENHANCE THE
REQUIREMENT OF
SAFETY MEASURES FOR HOSPITALS BY
REQUIRING COMMON SENSE MEASURES,
SUCH AS WEAPON DETECTION,
SCREENINGS AT SELECTIVE
ENTRANCES TO ENSURE
HOSPITALS REMAIN SAFE AND PLACE,
HEALING UM, AND NOT VIOLENCE.
AT THE FOREFRONT.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS MICHELLE HAMM,
UM, A KAISER, UH, WORKER, AND
ALSO, UM, FIONA, UH,
WHO'S A NURSE AT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY,
UM, MEDICAL CENTER,
A COUNTY HOSPITAL WILL ALSO SELF
INTRODUCE
WHO ARE MY LEAD WITNESSES.
WE'LL HAVE THE WITNESSES AT THE
PODIUM
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE HORN.
I'VE BEEN A REGISTERED NURSE IN
THE PACKAGE UNIT AT KAISER
PERMANENTE MORENO VALLEY
HOSPITAL FOR TEN YEARS.
I ALSO HAVE SEVEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AS AN E.R.
NURSE AT OTHER HOSPITALS.
SO I HAVE A DEEP UNDERSTANDING
OF THE MANY WORKPLACE
HAZARDS THAT NURSES FACE ON THE
JOB AT ANY HOSPITAL.
OF THE LONG LIST OF DANGERS THAT
NURSES
AND OTHER HEALTH CARE WORKERS
FACE DAILY,
THE POSSIBILITY OF AN
ENCOUNTERING
AN EMOTIONALLY CHARGED PATIENT
OR VISITOR WIELDING A DANGEROUS
WEAPON IS THE MOST TERRIFYING.
IT IS A VERY REAL THREAT TO OUR
SAFETY,
BUT IT IS ALSO ONE OF THE
EASIEST TO PREVENT.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS NO SINGLE
STATEWIDE POLICY
OR STANDARD TO ADDRESS THIS
THREAT.
INSTEAD, WE HAVE A PATCHWORK OF
DIFFERENT POLICIES DEVELOPED
BY INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS AT THEIR
OWN DISCRETION.
THAT IS NO WAY TO DEAL WITH SUCH
A PERVASIVE
AND LIFE THREATENING PROBLEM.
IN 2022, TWO NURSES AND A DOCTOR
WERE STABBED
AND IN ENCINO MEDICAL CENTER IN
LOS ANGELES BY A PATIENT WHO
ENTERED
THE HOSPITAL WITH A CONCEALED
KNIFE.
IT MAY BE THE MOST NOTORIOUS
EXAMPLE
OF HOSPITAL VIOLENCE IN OUR
AREA,
BUT IT COULD HAVE HAPPENED
ANYWHERE.
WE ARE URGING YOU TO PASS AB
SO THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
BY REQUIRING METAL DETECTORS,
TRAINED METAL DETECTORS STAFFED
BY TRAINED SECURITY OFFICERS AT
EVERY HOSPITAL,
WE CAN PROTECT PATIENTS AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH
CARE WITHOUT FEARING FOR OUR
OWN SAFETY.
FEAR IS WHAT I FELT WHEN A
PATIENT'S
INTOXICATED HUSBAND GOT IN MY
FACE
AND THREATENED ME WHILE HIS WIFE
WAS EXPERIENCING A MISCARRIAGE.
WE WERE WORKING TO ENSURE THAT
SHE DIDN'T
SUFFER ADDITIONAL COMPLICATIONS,
BUT HE WAS INCREASINGLY ERRATIC
AND IRRATIONAL,
BLAMING THE HOSPITAL STAFF
AND EVERYONE ELSE FOR HIS LOSS.
I KNEW HE COULD LASH OUT IN THE
STATE HE WAS IN,
BUT OUR HOSPITAL DID NOT HAVE
A POLICY
TO KEEP HIM FROM BRINGING IN
A WEAPON,
AND THAT SCARED ME THE MOST.
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I ASKED
SECURITY OFFICERS TO ESCORT
ME TO MY CAR AFTER MY SHIFT, BUT
NOT THE LAST.
ALL HEALTH CARE WORKERS SHOULD
BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON PROVIDING CARE,
NOT LOCATING THE THE NEAREST
EXIT
OR WHAT THEY COULD USE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES IN CASE THEY'RE
ATTACKED
OR TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS.
AB 2975 WILL MAKE OUR HOSPITAL
SAFER,
WHICH MEANS OUR PATIENTS WILL
GET BETTER CARE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI, MY NAME IS FIONA HANNON.
I AM A REGISTERED NURSE AT LA
COUNTY MEDICAL CENTER.
WE'VE JUST CHANGED OUR NAME TO
LA GENERAL,
SO I'VE BEEN THERE FOR 25 YEARS.
RIGHT BEFORE I STARTED, THERE
WERE THREE
DOCTORS THAT WERE SHOT IN OUR
EMERGENCY
ROOM BECAUSE A PATIENT WANTED
PAIN MEDICATION
AND THOUGHT THE WAIT WAS TOO
LONG.
SO I FEEL COMFORTABLE GOING
TO WORK
EVERY DAY KNOWING THAT NOW,
OUR HOSPITAL USED COMMON SENSE
AND IT DOES HAVE METAL DETECTION
SYSTEM THERE WHERE WE JUST WALK
THROUGH THE DOORS.
IT DOESN'T SLOW EVERYTHING DOWN
BECAUSE
YOU JUST WALK RIGHT THROUGH.
SO WE FEEL SAFE GOING TO WORK.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU DO HAVE
PATIENTS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
YOU HAVE JUST GENERAL PEOPLE
WE'RE IN AN AREA WHERE YOU HAVE
GANGS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
WEAPONS COME IN.
THEY RETRIEVE SOME WEAPONS
THROUGH THE E.R.,
BUT THEY DON'T GET EVERYTHING.
THIS IS A WAY TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE'S
GOING TO BE SAFE AGAIN.
PATIENT SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE
STAFF SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FEAR GOING
TO
WORK TO TAKE CARE OF OTHER
PEOPLE,
SAVING LIVES, KNOWING THAT OUR
LIVES COULD BE IN JEOPARDY.
SO I AM DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2975.
I THINK, UM, THEY SHOULD BE
INSTALLED AT ALL HOSPITALS.
I'M SAD SADDENED TO SEE THAT
THE PREVIOUS NURSE DOESN'T HAVE
ANY,
UH, COMING INTO THIS BUILDING.
WE WENT THROUGH METAL DETECTION,
I WENT THROUGH THE AIRPORT,
WE GO THROUGH METAL DETECTION.
EVERYWHERE YOU GO, YOU HAVE IT.
EVEN BASIC CONCERTS, YOU CAN'T.
YOU HAVE TO CARRY SEE THROUGH
BAGS.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER FAIL SAFE STEP
FOR EVERYONE
TO FEEL SAFE COMING INTO OUR
BUILDINGS.
AND I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE IN
EVERY SINGLE HOSPITAL.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO LISTEN TO ME.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, NOW WE'LL HAVE WITNESSES.
UH, NOT WITNESSES, BUT FOLKS
WHO WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT.
>> OKAY.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES,
WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
IS THEIR WITNESS?
OKAY.
WITNESSES.
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
CHAIR, SENATORS, COMMITTEE
STAFF.
I'LL BE BRIEF.
MY NAME IS DEAN GRIFFITH WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
WE REMAIN IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 2975.
PATIENT AND EMPLOYEE SAFETY WILL
ALWAYS
BE A TOP PRIORITY FOR OUR
HOSPITALS.
WHILE WE'RE STILL REVIEWING
THESE RECENT AMENDMENTS,
WHICH MAKE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
STEP
AND ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE
THE HARD WORK BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON AND HIS TEAM,
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
PEREZ.
AND THE BILL SPONSOR.
CALIFORNIA.
SEIU CALIFORNIA.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH ALL,
ALL TOWARDS A CREATIVE SOLUTION
ON THAT SHARED
PRIORITY OF PATIENT AND EMPLOYEE
SAFETY.
THANK YOU.
>> UH, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBER SARAH
BRIDGE,
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
HERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED,
TO AB 2975.
HD REPRESENTS THE 77 PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
OVER HALF OF WHICH OWN AND OR
OPERATE A HOSPITAL.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
AUTHOR,
SPONSORS AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR
CONTINUED WORK ON THE BILL.
WE FEEL LIKE THE BILL IS MOVING
IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION.
HOWEVER, AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
REMAINED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL AND THE POTENTIAL
LIABILITIES IT CREATES.
DISTRICT HOSPITALS PRIORITY AND
PRIMARY CONCERN
IS THE SAFETY OF OUR STAFF AND
PATIENTS.
IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS, WE WANT
TO ENSURE
THAT THE SHARED GOAL OF MAKING
HOSPITALS A SAFER PLACE CAN
ACTUALLY
BE ACHIEVED THROUGH THE BILL.
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS,
HOSPITALS ARE FEDERALLY REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO CARE FOR ALL PATIENTS
SEEKING
HOSPITAL AND EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO FEDERAL
OR STATE STATUTES ALLOWING
A HOSPITAL TO REJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS SEEKING CARE,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN ITEM THAT
MAY CONSTITUTE A WEAPON.
FURTHER, HOSPITALS ARE NOT, NOT,
AND NOR SHOULD THEY BE STORAGE
FACILITIES FOR PERSONAL
PROPERTY,
UM, ESPECIALLY WEAPONS.
OUR HOSPITALS WANT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PATIENTS
CAN FREELY ACCESS THE HOSPITAL
SERVICES
WITHOUT THE CHILLING EFFECT
OF METAL
THAT A METAL DETECTOR MAY CAUSE.
FURTHER, WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR
HOSPITALS ARE NOT CONFISCATING
PERSONAL PROPERTY OF THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS,
NOR DO WE WANT TO HAVE TO ENGAGE
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
IT MAY NOT ALWAYS BE WARRANTED
AND OR APPROPRIATE.
FOR OUR SMALL RURAL PROVIDERS,
THE INSTALLATION
AND OPERATION OF METAL DETECTORS
CREATE SIGNIFICANT SPATIAL AND
FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES FOR THESE PROVIDERS.
A HANDHELD METAL DETECTOR, ALSO
KNOWN AS A WAND,
MAY BE THE MOST FEASIBLE OPTION.
HOWEVER, PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ONLY
ALLOW THESE PROVEN TOOLS TO
BE USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
ANOTHER
METAL DETECTION SYSTEM,
ALLOWING A WAND TO BE USED IN
CERTAIN CASES
AS A SOLE DETECTION SYSTEM WOULD
ACHIEVE
THE GOAL OF THE BILL WHILE
ENSURING THAT
OUR PROVIDERS CAN MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS.
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS MOVE
THE BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR AND ARE CONFIDENT WE
CAN FIND A APPROPRIATE APPROACH.
HOWEVER, AT THIS TIME WE REMAIN
OPPOSE UNLESS FURTHER AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ALSO WISHING TO
SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION.
>> I THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS HERE WITH A CONCERNS
POSITION, JEAN HEARST,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS.
OUR CONCERNS ARE SIMILAR TO
THOSE EXPRESSED
BY THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE ASSOCIATION
OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND SEEING NO ONE ELSE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION,
WE'LL MOVE TO THE DAIS.
SO I WILL JUST SAY TO THE
AUTHOR,
THANK YOU FOR FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS AND GLAD THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO REACH,
UM, AGREEMENT.
UM, OF COURSE, MAKING SURE
WORKERS ARE SAFE IS
THE ABSOLUTE UTMOST PRIORITY FOR
FOR THIS COMMITTEE,
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE PATIENTS
AND VISITORS ARE SAFE
AS WELL AND THAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE PROTECTED.
WE KNOW TOO OFTEN WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT SURVEILLANCE.
UM, UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF CERTAIN
GROUPS HAVING DISPARATE OUTCOMES
WITH THAT.
AND I THINK THIS IS A WAY FOR
US TO ADDRESS
IT BY MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROPER
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE THAT ENSURES
THAT
EVERYONE'S RIGHTS ARE RESPECTED.
SO WITH THAT, I WANT TO SAY,
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO CLOSE,
AND WE LIKELY WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL
AS WE WAIT FOR OUR MEMBERS TO
SHOW UP.
SURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE AGAIN THE WORK FROM
YOUR COMMITTEE
AND AND WORKING WITH MY TEAM.
AND ALSO FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL,
I THINK THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATION.
UM, BUT I APPRECIATE MY
WITNESSES
WHO CAME FORWARD, MISS HAHN,
AND ALSO, UM, UH, FIONA WHO CAME
FORTH TO TALK ABOUT ONE.
WE HAVE WE DON'T LIVE IN A TIME
THAT WE DID 20, 30 YEARS AGO.
LET'S BE REAL.
WE FIND OURSELVES IF CHURCH IS
NO LONGER SAFE,
NIGHTCLUBS NO LONGER SAFE,
PLACES OF WORSHIP ARE NO LONGER
SAFE, RIGHT?
CHURCHES ARE MOVING TO PUTTING
IN METAL
DETECTORS AND WANTING
INDIVIDUALS
TO MAKING SURE THAT THE PLACE
OF WORSHIP
IS A PLACE OF PEACE AND SAFETY.
SHOULDN'T OUR FRONTLINE HOSPITAL
WORKERS HAVE
THAT SAME KIND OF SECURITY GOING
TO WORK?
SHOULDN'T OUR PATIENTS ALSO HAVE
THAT SAME KIND OF SECURITY
GOING INTO THE HOSPITAL TO HAVE
NURSES BE TO BECOME,
UH, SECURITY OFFICERS, THEY NEED
TO BE ON THE FRONT
LINE LIKE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
ON THE FRONT LINE.
AND THAT IS PROVIDING THE CARE
AND THE NEEDS
AND THE SUPPORT THAT FAMILIES
NEED.
AND THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING THE
HEALING WHEN
IT COMES TO THE HOSPITAL NEEDS
MOST.
AND SO, AGAIN, EVEN IN THIS
BUILDING,
WE COME THROUGH THIS BUILDING.
WHY DO WE HAVE METAL DETECTORS?
WHY DO WE HAVE PEOPLE WITH WANDS
TO
MAKING SURE THAT NO ONE BRINGS
ANY KIND OF WEAPONS IN THAT
WOULD
DO ANY HARM TO ANY ONE OF US?
THE SAME THING WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO CONCERTS.
SO WE LIVE IN A DIFFERENT TIME,
SO WE CAN'T USE WHAT WE WHAT WE
USE OR IMPLEMENT IT 20 OR 30
YEARS
AGO THAT TIME DOESN'T EXIST.
AND SO THIS IS A THOUGHTFUL, UM,
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
MAKING SURE THAT
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS
UNDERSCORE
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS GO TO
WORK
AND LEAVE IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
SO
THEY CAN GO HOME SO THEY CAN
COME
BACK THE NEXT DAY AND HEAL THOSE
WHO
NEED THE HEALING MOST OF ALL.
AND SO AGAIN, THIS IS A SENSIBLE
MEASURE.
UM, AND THE TESTIMONIES ARE
LEGITIMATE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ASK
FOR
AN I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GLAD TO
SEE THAT
YOU'RE WELL AND HEALTHY AND
WITH US.
AND WE WILL TAKE THAT MOTION
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM.
SO THANK YOU.
VERY APPRECIATE YOU.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK INTO
FILE ORDER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA AB 2068.
AND I THINK YOU WILL ALSO BE
PRESENTING
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON AS
WELL.
WE'LL DO WE'LL TAKE THEM BOTH UP
AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
>> THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
SENATORS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2068 TODAY.
AB 2068 WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA
STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS THAT CONTRACT
THEIR PUBLIC
AND CUSTOMER CALL CENTER
SERVICES TO OUT OF STATE
TO PROVIDE A FULL LIST OF THESE
CONTRACTS.
IN RECENT YEARS, THERE HAS BEEN
AN INDICATION
THAT THESE CALIFORNIA AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENT CALL CENTERS
ARE NOW
BEING LOCATED IN OTHER STATES,
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE PAID
EXCLUSIVELY
BY CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
IT IS A CHALLENGING TO DEVELOP
A PLAN TO
BRING THESE JOBS BACK TO
CALIFORNIA,
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBER
OF STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENT
CALL CENTERS POSITIONS THAT ARE
LOCATED OUTSIDE OF THE STATE.
AB 2068 WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE
TO GATHER
A MASTER LIST OF ALL OUT OF
STATE
CALL CENTERS THAT THE STATE
AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS HAVE SIGNED,
THE COST OF CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS,
AND THE NUMBER AND TYPES OF
JOBS FOUND
IN OTHER STATE'S WITNESSES.
I HAVE ONE WITNESS TODAY TO
TESTIFY,
AND THAT IS IGNACIO HERNANDEZ
WITH THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS
OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICT NINE.
GREAT.
WE'LL TAKE THEM AT THE PODIUM.
PLEASE PROCEED.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS DISTRICT NINE,
WHICH ENCOMPASSES CALIFORNIA,
NEVADA AND HAWAII.
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE
MEASURE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE BILL.
AS WAS INDICATED, WE HAVE SEEN
A MIGRATION OF CALL CENTER JOBS,
BOTH IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND
PRIVATE SECTOR OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SOMETIMES OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
IT'S PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC
WHEN WE HAVE STATE DOLLARS,
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BEING SPENT
FOR THESE JOBS
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA INSTEAD
OF IN STATE,
AND REALLY PROBLEMATIC WHEN
SOMEONE IS CALLING
A PUBLIC ENTITY AND EXPECTING
TO HAVE A CUSTOMER
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND INSTEAD
THOSE CALL CENTERS GOING
ELSEWHERE,
IT'S A PROBLEM BOTH FOR THE
CONSUMER CALLING IN,
BUT ALSO A PROBLEM FOR THE JOB
CREATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE BEEN LOSING THESE
JOBS.
THERE WAS A SACRAMENTO CALL
CENTER SPECIFICALLY
FOR STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENT.
JUST AS ONE EXAMPLE, A FEW YEARS
AGO I HAD OVER 200 WORKERS.
THEY'RE NOW DOWN TO ABOUT 20.
AND THAT IS BEING REPEATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO THESE ARE AND I HAVE TO
REMIND YOU,
THESE ARE JOBS THAT ARE NOT JUST
SHORT TERM JOBS.
THEY OFTENTIMES BECOME CAREERS
FOR WORKERS.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING UP
MIDDLE CLASS AND BUILDING UP
WAYS TO HELP,
UM, YOU KNOW, INCREASE, UH,
WORKER OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS ONE WAY WE CAN DO
IT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET
THIS INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH
DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES HAVE CONTRACTS FOR
CALL CENTER JOBS OUT OF STATE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
GATHER THAT INFORMATION,
AND IT'S NOT READILY AVAILABLE
SO THAT WE CAN COME
UP WITH A GAME PLAN TO BRING
THESE JOBS BACK.
SO THIS BILL WOULD MOVE US IN
THAT
DIRECTION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO HOPEFULLY YOUR SUPPORT WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
OKAY.
ANYONE HERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR SANDRA
BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAT MORAN
WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PORT.
OKAY.
WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SPEAKING TODAY?
OKAY.
ANYONE JUST SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL TODAY?
OKAY.
UH.
WE WILL MOVE TO THE DAIS.
SENATOR WILKES.
YEAH.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT.
I'VE ALREADY SEEN THIS IN GEO.
SUPPORTED THEIR PLAN TO SUPPORT
IT HERE.
I THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT
A THAT ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCIES
WILL NOT REPORT BACK INFORMATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY
FOR OVERSIGHT AND SO.
AND I MEAN, I AGREE, IF WE'RE
SPENDING TAXPAYER MONEY,
WE OUGHT TO BE SPENDING IT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND WE'LL
SUPPORT IT AGAIN TODAY.
ARE YOU MAKING THE MOTION?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
WHEN THE TIME WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT WE WILL
HOLD FOR OUR MOTION ONCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OH, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I WILL USE SENATOR WILKES AS
MY CLOSING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL MOVE THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11 AB 2754.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPEAKER EMERITUS,
ANTHONY RENDON.
AB 2754 WILL PROVIDE GREATER
EMPLOYMENT PROTECTION
TO PORT DRAYAGE TRUCK DRIVERS
ACROSS THE STATE
BY ENSURING COMPANIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THEM ARE
HELD LIABLE FOR ANY VIOLATIONS
OF LABOR LAW.
MAKING THESE CARGO OWNERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LABOR
LAW VIOLATIONS WILL INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO
CONTRACT ONLY WITH COMPANIES
THAT FOLLOW
THE LAW AND PROPERLY CLASSIFY
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
FURTHERMORE, THIS BILL WILL
PUSH THESE
COMPANIES TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
CONTRACTS CAN SATISFY LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS
TO THEIR TO THEIR WORKERS.
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS SHANE GUZMAN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL.
>> MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SHANE GUSMAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL,
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
UM, AS UH, THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID,
THE THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS A PROBLEM
THAT IS A DECADES OLD PROBLEM
IN OUR PORTS.
UM, MISCLASSIFICATION OF TRUCK
DRIVERS.
UM, WE TOOK A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
AS THE BILL MOVED ALONG.
UM, WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER OPPONENTS.
UM, I BELIEVE MOST, IF NOT ALL
OF
THE OPPOSITION IS IS NOW
NEUTRAL.
UM, JUST TO CLARIFY, THERE WAS
A PROVISION
QUOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
UM, THE OPPONENTS ARGUMENTS THAT
WAS ON A EARLIER VERSION
OF THE BILL THAT IS NO LONGER
PART OF THE BILL.
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET EVERYBODY
TO NEUTRAL
AT SOME POINT OR DRIVE UP.
YOU SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES?
LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
OH, SORRY.
WE ARE DOING SUPPORT THOSE WHO
ARE TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
YVONNE FERNANDEZ,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT.
OKAY.
NOW, SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES,
LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
ANY ONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL TODAY?
SEEING NONE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
I VOTE WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL HOLD THIS FOR MOTION
WHEN WE HAVE OUR QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO GO ON TO
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW WHO'S NEXT UP.
AND LET'S FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB 2421.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2421
TO HELP STRENGTHEN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN UNION
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS MANY IN
THE WORKPLACE.
THIS IS TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH EMPLOYEES DISCUSS
WORKPLACE MATTERS,
SUCH AS DISCIPLINE OR GRIEVANCES
WITH THEIR UNION REPRESENTATIVE,
OFTENTIMES TO BE ADDRESSED WITH
CONVERSATIONS
TO BE MADE CONFIDENTIAL.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES REPRESENTING PAURAQUE
IF THEY ARE HERE.
OH, YES, MR.
TALBOT, AND RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR.
I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
PLEASE APPROACH THE PODIUM.
MR.
TALBOT, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TIM TALBOT, I AM
HERE,
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF PAURAQUE,
WHO IS A SPONSOR OF THE BILL
TO ENSURE
PUBLIC SECTOR LABOR UNIONS
FUNCTION AS GUARANTEED
BY CALIFORNIA'S COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING LAWS.
UNION MEMBERS MUST BE ASSURED
THAT WHAT THEY TELL
THEIR UNION REPRESENTATIVES IN
CONFIDENCE
CANNOT BE FORCED OUT OF THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES
BY GOVERNMENT,
EMPLOYERS OR THEIR AGENTS.
UNION MEMBERS MUST KNOW AND BE
SECURE
IN FEELING THAT UNION
REPRESENTATIVES
WILL NOT BE TRANSFORMED INTO
UNWILLING
AGENTS OF THE EMPLOYER.
AB 2421 ACCOMPLISHES THESE
OBJECTIVES
AND ALIGNS WITH EXISTING
PRECEDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD, OR PERB.
PERB IS HELD THAT QUESTIONING
UNION
MEMBERS OR UNION REPRESENTATIVES
ABOUT UNION ACTIVITIES OR
REPRESENTATION UNLAWFULLY
INTERFERES WITH THE RIGHTS OF
THE UNION MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC
SECTOR UNIONS AND CONSTITUTES
AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE.
AB 2421 WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT
SUCH INTERFERENCE
WITH UNION REPRESENTATION
BY PUBLIC EMPLOYERS IS UNLAWFUL
AND AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE.
THE BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
EMPLOYERS
FROM QUESTIONING EMPLOYEES,
OR FROM PROHIBIT EMPLOYEES FROM
VOLUNTEERING
OR SHARING INFORMATION ABOUT
WORKPLACE SAFETY
OR PROBLEMATIC CONDUCT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
EMPLOYEES REMAIN FREE TO
VOLUNTARILY
SHARE ANY SUCH INFORMATION
WITH THE EMPLOYERS IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SO.
BUT WHAT EMPLOYERS CANNOT DO
IS QUESTION
THE UNION EMPLOYEE OR THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE
ABOUT CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS RELATING
SPECIFICALLY TO THE
REPRESENTATION.
WE, PERAK AMENDED THIS BILL ON
OUR OWN TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY DOES
NOT APPLY TO COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN UNION
MEMBERS AND UNION
REPRESENTATIVES,
WHO ARE THEMSELVES WITNESSES TO
OR INVOLVED IN THE EVENTS,
GIVING RISE TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE,
DISCIPLINARY OR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS
OF UNION MEMBERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT ELIMINATES THE
CONCERN
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY EXPRESSED,
BUT QUESTIONING A UNION
REPRESENTATIVE
WHOSE ONLY ROLE IN
THE MATTER IS FROM THEIR STATUS
AS A UNION REPRESENTATIVE,
SERVES NO PURPOSE EXCEPT TO
FISH FOR UNION STRATEGIES
AND POSSIBLE EMPLOYEE
CONFESSIONS,
AND TURN THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE INTO A WITNESS
AGAINST THE UNION AND ITS
MEMBERS.
SUCH CONDUCT INTERFERES WITH
THE BASIC
AND IMPORTANT FUNCTION OF LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS,
WHICH IS TO PROVIDE ADVICE
AND COUNSEL TO MEMBERS REGARDING
MATTERS WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
REPRESENTATION.
AB 2421 SENSIBLY PREVENTS SUCH
INTERFERENCE
WITH UNION REPRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANOTHER WITNESS?
OKAY.
NO WITNESS.
SO NOW WE'LL JUST GO TO SUPPORT.
OH.
YOU ARE.
OH, NO.
OH.
I'M JUST.
PLEASE JUST SUPPORT.
OKAY.
PAT MORAN, AARON READING
ASSOCIATES,
WE REPRESENT THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AS CO SPONSORING
THE BILL AT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN.
ALSO CO-SPONSORING THE BILL, THE
ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS UAW 1115, IN SUPPORT
AS WELL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> MADAM CHAIR, MATT BRAUDE HERE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL?
OKAY, WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
OR IS THERE AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS?
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> THANK YOU.
SARAH DUQUETTE, ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS,
THE BILL WILL INTERFERE WITH
OUR ABILITY
TO ENSURE A SAFE WORKPLACE,
EVEN WITH THE CHANGES TO THE
INTENT LANGUAGE,
THE SUBSTANTIVE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL REMAIN LARGELY
UNCHANGED AND WILL FUNCTION LIKE
A PRIVILEGE.
WHILE THE AMENDMENTS ASSERT THAT
THIS ACT
DOES NOT CREATE AN EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE,
HOW THE PROVISIONS MIGHT
INTERACT
WITH JUDICIAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE PROCEEDINGS IS DEEPLY
UNCLEAR.
AT BEST, IT COULD EASILY BE
INTERPRETED
IN CIVIL LITIGATION THAT THIRD
PARTIES,
I.E., THE PLAINTIFF SUING AN
AGENCY,
CAN COMPEL ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION,
BUT THE AGENCY ITSELF CANNOT
COMPEL ACCESS TO OR DISCLOSE OF
THE INFORMATION IN ITS DEFENSE.
IN ADDITION, AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS AN EXCEPTION
FOR WHEN THE EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVE IS
A WITNESS OR PARTY TO ANY OF THE
EVENTS FORMING
THE BASIS OF POTENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE,
DISCIPLINARY OR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION
ARE EXCEPTIONALLY NARROW.
TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS NOT A
COMPLETE EXEMPTION
FOR CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS.
RATHER, IT APPLIES ONLY WHEN
THE EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE
THEMSELVES WAS A WITNESS OR
PARTY TO AN EVENT.
IT DOES NOT COVER THE LIKELY
SCENARIO IN WHICH
AN EMPLOYEE WHO WAS A WITNESS
OR PARTY,
OR PERPETRATOR OR VICTIM,
PROVIDES RELEVANT
INFORMATION TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE.
THIS IS BOTH PROBLEMATIC FOR
CRIMINAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED HOW THIS
BILL INTERACTS
WITH RECENTLY ENACTED SB 553
COURTESY,
WHICH PROVIDES A NEW STRUCTURE
AND REQUIREMENTS FOR
PREVENTING AND INVESTIGATING
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE.
IF THE EMPLOYER IS LIMITED IN
ITS
COMMUNICATIONS WITH EMPLOYEES,
IT WILL MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO
COMPLY WITH THESE LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS.
TO CREATE A SAFE WORKPLACE
SHOULD
ALSO BE NOTED THAT SB
553 WILL ALLOW COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVES
STANDING TO SEEK TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS
IN CONNECTION WITH WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE.
AB 2400 21ST MAY CREATE A
PROBLEMATIC
SCENARIO WHEREIN
SUCH A TRO MAY BE SOUGHT BY AN
EMPLOYER,
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO FULLY
INVESTIGATE
THE UNDERLYING FACTS.
IN CONCLUSION, EVEN AS AMENDED,
AB 2421 WOULD INTERFERE WITH
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYER'S
RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROVIDE A SAFE
WORKPLACE BY IMPEDING THEIR
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
EMPLOYEES TO INVESTIGATE
AND RESPOND TO SUCH CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, SO THAT WAS OUR LAST
WITNESS.
ARE YOU THE SECOND WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION?
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR JOHNNY PINA WITH THE
LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
HERE TODAY IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 2421.
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED, WHILE THE
PRIOR INTENT
LANGUAGE REFERENCING A PRIVILEGE
HAS BEEN REMOVED AS SUBSTANCE OF
THE BILL REMAINS LARGELY THE
SAME,
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH ISSUES RAISED
IN PREVIOUS RAISED IN RESPONSE
TO SIMILAR LEGISLATION,
SUCH AS AB 418 FROM 2019,
AND REFLECTED IN THE VETO
MESSAGE
OF AB 729 FROM 2013.
THIS BILL IS BROAD AND CAN BE
READ TO PROHIBIT EMPLOYERS
FROM COMMUNICATING WITH
EMPLOYEES ABOUT
ANYTHING FROM DAY TO DAY
ACTIVITIES,
TO MATTERS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
FOR CITY OPERATIONS.
EMPLOYERS MAY NOT KNOW WHEN THEY
ARE VIOLATING
THE BILL BY COMMUNICATING WITH
STAFF,
BECAUSE ONLY THE EMPLOYEE OR
THE REPRESENTATIVE WOULD KNOW,
OR COULD OR COULD DECIDE WHEN
A COMMUNICATION
WAS MADE IN CONFIDENCE.
ADDITIONALLY, THE TERM EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVE
AND ADMINISTRATIVE
DISCIPLINARY INVESTIGATION IS
NOT DEFINED WITHIN THE BILL,
LEAVING THE BILL'S APPLICATION
SUBJECT TO
INTERPRETATION AND POSSIBLE
DISPUTE.
IN ORDER TO CONDUCT PROPER
INVESTIGATIONS
THAT UPHOLD THE PUBLIC'S TRUST,
IT IS CRITICAL THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYER
HAVE THE ABILITY TO INTERVIEW
ALL POTENTIAL PARTIES AND
WITNESSES
TO ASCERTAIN THE FACTS.
THE BILL COULD INTERFERE WITH
INVESTIGATIONS BECAUSE
THE EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE
COULD POTENTIALLY
PREVENT AN EMPLOYER FROM
COMMUNICATING FROM
COMPLETING A COMPREHENSIVE
INVESTIGATION.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 2421 LACKS
SAFEGUARDS
TO PREVENT POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST THAT COULD ARISE
DURING EMPLOYEE CONFLICTS,
UNLIKE OTHER TYPES OF PRIVILEGE
THAT ARE CAREFULLY DEFINED.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ESTABLISH
SPECIFIC GUIDELINES
OR REQUIRED TRAINING FOR THE
EMPLOYEE REPS.
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, SO THOSE, UH,
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION, THE
BILL,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
>> MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEPHANIE
ROBERSON,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO MR.
LO'S BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
CAITLIN DEANE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, GENE HEARST
HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA.
UH, ALSO IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION,
I'D LIKE TO ALSO COMMUNICATE
THE OPPOSITION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION
AND PARK DISTRICTS,
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES,
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS,
AND PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS
AND MANAGEMENT PRISM AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, ANDREW
MARTINEZ,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA,
ALSO OPPOSED.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
DOROTHY JOHNSON, ON BEHALF
OF ACTS OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, I GUESS AT THIS POINT I
WILL ASK YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR.
JUST FOR THE PUBLIC INTEREST
AS WELL TO AND ACKNOWLEDGING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED.
NUMBER ONE, OF COURSE, IT IS
OUR OBLIGATION
TO HELP ADDRESS ANY OF
THESE ISSUES FOR THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN,
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
THROUGH YOUR COMMITTEE,
AND JUST TO REAFFIRM THE
IMPORTANCE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAMPER THE
WORKPLACE,
UH, INVESTIGATIONS OR
ALLEGATIONS
OF DISCRIMINATION,
HARASSMENT OR WORKPLACE SAFETY,
THAT IS, OF COURSE,
NOT THE INTENT AT ALL AND HAPPY
TO ADDRESS ANY ADDITIONAL
OF THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
AND I ACKNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE
THAT I SUPPORT
WHEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME
BECOMES AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AS SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
HERE,
WE'LL TAKE UP THE MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
SO WE WILL GIVE A LITTLE TIME
FOR TRANSITION
AND MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB 2284.
SYMBOL.
MEMBER.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS,
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN, FIRST
OF ALL,
WITH A SINCERE THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU SO VERY, VERY MUCH.
AND I DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
SO, AGAIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TO CHAIR AB
2284,
AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT LAW OF 1937,
OR SERAL RETIREMENT SYSTEMS,
TO DEFINE GRADE AS A GROUP OF
EMPLOYEES
BASED ON SHARED SIMILARITIES IN
THEIR JOB DUTIES,
THEIR SCHEDULES, WORK LOCATIONS,
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT,
OR AMONG OTHER LOGICAL WORK
RELATED
GROUPINGS FOR THE PURPOSES
OF THE CALCULATION OF
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION.
THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA
OPERATES UNDER TWO DISTINCT
PROVISIONS
EITHER THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT LAW OR
THE COUNTY EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
LAW OF 1937.
SARAH SEARLE GOVERNS RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS
FOR COUNTY AND DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES UNDER
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION IS
DEFINED
AS THE AVERAGE COMPENSATION UPON
THE BASIS OF THE AVERAGE NUMBER
OF DAYS ORDINARILY
WORKED BY PERSONS IN THE SAME
GRADE,
CLASS, OR POSITIONS DURING THE
PERIOD,
OR AT THE SAME RATE OF PAY.
PEARL OVERSEES THE
ADMINISTRATION
OF CALPERS FOR
THE EMPLOYEES FOR BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THIS GROUP PROVIDES A CLEAR
DEFINITION OF GROUP
OR CLASS EMPLOYMENT UTILIZED
AS PART
OF ITS DEFINITION OF PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION,
WHEREAS SARAH, ON THE OTHER
HAND,
THIS DOES NOT PROVIDE A CLEAR
DEFINITION FOR THAT PORTION
OF THEIR PROVISIONS OF
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION,
INTRODUCING WHAT WE WOULD KNOW
AS AMBIGUITY
AND POTENTIAL DISPARITIES.
THIS AMBIGUITY IS WHAT
COMPENSATION
ITEMS ARE PENSIONABLE
THAT CAN LEAD TO REDUCED
RETIREMENTS.
SO AB 2284 ADDRESSES THIS
INCONSISTENCY AND WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR THE COUNTY
RETIREMENT
SYSTEM BY CREATING A DEFINITION
FOR AND I QUOTE
GRADE SIMILAR TO ONE FOUND IN
PEARL.
FOR THE TERM GROUP, THE
CONSISTENCY
WILL REDUCE THE LEGAL BURDENS
FOR ALL PARTIES AS WELL AS ALLOW
FOR SECURE RETIREMENTS.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS
BILL IS PERMISSIVE AND IN
NATURE,
AND DOES NOT RESTRICT RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS
FROM MAKING THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
THEY CAN STILL MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS.
SO WITH THAT, THROUGH THE CHAIR,
I DO HAVE WITNESSES THAT I WILL
HAVE
SELF INTRODUCE WONDERFUL
WITNESSES.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD TO THE MIC.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
SHANE LEVINE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE.
UM, THANK YOU AND THANK THE
AUTHOR.
UM, MR.
GRAYSON, I WON'T TAKE UP TOO
MUCH TIME.
HE SAID EVERYTHING VERY, VERY
WELL.
UM, BUT WE DID HAVE SOME
EMPLOYEE ASSOCIATIONS
COME TO US TO SUGGEST
THAT THERE WAS NEEDED CLARITY
IN THIS DEFINITION IN SEARLE.
IT'S NOT ALREADY THERE.
UM, SO THAT'S EFFECTIVELY WHAT
THIS
BILL DOES IS PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT
OF CLARITY AND SOME GUIDANCE FOR
THE SYSTEMS THAT CHOOSE, AS MR.
GRAYSON ARTICULATED, TO USE THIS
DEFINITION,
IT IS A MAY IT IS PERMISSIVE.
NO SYSTEM IN THE SEARLE SYSTEM
HAS TO USE THIS DEFINITION.
UM, TO THE OPPOSITION.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME LATE
OPPOSITION
INTO THAT OPPOSITION
THAT HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT IN
THEIR POSITIONS.
I THINK WE'LL PROBABLY GET THERE
WITH THIS AMENDMENT
THAT WE'RE ACCEPTING FROM THE
COMMITTEE,
I THINK MAY RESOLVE A LOT OF
THOSE DIFFERENCES,
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION.
SO WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
DOUG SUBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
I WON'T TRY TO BE TOO
REPETITIVE,
BUT I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL.
WE REPRESENT 35,000 MEMBERS,
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
WHICH ARE IN COUNTY EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
SO IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE, UH,
WHEN WE HEAR FROM THEM ABOUT
ISSUES
OR AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW,
WE ALWAYS WORK TO SEEK TO
ADDRESS
THEM AND PROVIDE CLARITY.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS BILL
DOES THAT
FOR SO SO FOR THESE REASONS,
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
OH.
I'M SORRY.
ME TOO.
FOR SUPPORT.
ANY FOLKS WANT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION.
OKAY.
I DIDN'T SEE ANYONE LINING UP,
SO WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANYONE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
THE WITNESSES.
HOW ABOUT ME?
TOS?
ANY OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE.
I WANT TO JUST SAY THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH COMMITTEE ON
THIS.
UM, YOU KNOW.
THESE BILLS ARE HARD BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PENSIONS ARE
PROTECTED.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU AND THE
SPONSORS
REALLY STEPPING FORWARD AND
HELPING
US DEAL WITH THE REALITY THAT
WE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, 20 DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
AND SOMETIMES WE'RE PURSUING THE
SAME APPROACH.
UM, BUT THOSE APPROACHES MIGHT
BE IN SOME WAYS COLLIDING.
AND I THINK THIS WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO REALLY LOOK AT
THIS BODY OF LAW AND FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
WITHOUT IN ANY WAY UNDERMINING
THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM
AND THE PROTECTION OF WORKERS
IN THEIR IN THEIR RETIREMENT.
AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU
ACKNOWLEDGED THE AMENDMENTS.
THEY MIGHT NOT COVER EVERY
POSSIBLE
PROBLEM AND SCENARIO.
SO THIS MIGHT NOT BE THE ONLY
TIME
THAT WE'LL BE WORKING ON THIS.
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU'RE COMMITTED
TO FUTURE DIALOGUE AND SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION THAT'S JUST SORT
OF COME
FORWARD AND WORKING THROUGH IT.
SO I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN
IT'S
TIME AND WHEN WE ALSO GET A
QUORUM,
WE'LL HAVE A MOTION AND WE'LL
MOVE IT FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL TAKE A BRIEF RECESS
AS WE WAIT FOR PRESENTERS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER UM HANEY
CALDERON.
UM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
ARAMBULA.
UM ASSEMBLY MEMBER, UH MCCARTY,
UH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF BURR.
UH, PLEASE COME TO LABOR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA.
WE'RE WAITING FOR YOU.
AND UNTIL THEY ARRIVE, WE WILL
BE IN RECESS.
AND WE WILL COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE IN 10S.
>> WHAT ABOUT LISA?
>> WHAT'S UP MAN?
HEY BROTHER.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, WE ARE
RECONVENED.
COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT.
WE SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY
IS HERE.
WE WILL GO AND FILE SOMEWHAT.
FILE ORDER WITH YOU.
ITEM FILE, ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB 20.
I'M SORRY, AB 31 9024 EIGHT
IS ALL.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS AB 3190 WILL ENSURE
THAT EVERY CONSTRUCTION
WORKER ON AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT IS BEING PAID A FAIR
WAGE,
WHILE ALSO ADVANCING OUR STATE'S
HOUSING GOALS.
IT ADDRESSES A SIGNIFICANT
LOOPHOLE
IN EXISTING PUBLIC
WORKS LAW THAT HAS PREVENTED
CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS
FROM RECEIVING PREVAILING WAGES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
FUNDED
THROUGH STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS
AND STATE OR LOCAL BELOW MARKET
RATE LOANS ARE
EXEMPT FROM PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM HAS GROWN TO
PROVIDE
NEARLY $500 MILLION PER YEAR TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS,
AND BELOW MARKET RATE LOANS
CONTRIBUTE
AN ADDITIONAL 700
MILLION PER YEAR IN FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE INCREASE IN THE USE OF BOTH
OF THESE FUNDS,
AND THEIR EXEMPTION FROM PUBLIC
WORKS
LAW AROUND PREVAILING WAGE,
MEANS THAT MANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING
PROJECTS IN OUR STATE
DO NOT PAY THE WORKERS ON THESE
JOBS AT PREVAILING WAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PREVAILING
WAGE EXEMPTIONS,
AS WELL AS THE LACK OF BENEFITS
AND WAGE THEFT,
PREVENT THE STATE FROM
RECRUITING CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS TO WORK ON HOUSING
PROJECTS.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS 100,000 MORE
RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
TO MEET THE STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS.
IT NEEDS AN ADDITIONAL 200,000
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS TO MEET
THE STATE'S OVERALL GOALS.
DUE TO THE LOWER WAGES, THE
STATE IS UNABLE
TO RETAIN AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WORKFORCE,
WITH MANY CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
CHOOSING TO
WORK ON NON HOUSING PROJECTS
INSTEAD.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR
SOLUTION TO THESE CHALLENGES
AND ALSO HOPEFULLY MAKE SURE
THAT
WE CAN PAY THESE WORKERS
WHAT THEY DESERVE AND THAT THEY
THEMSELVES CAN AFFORD TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES
AND ACCESS HOUSING.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY
IS JAY BRADSHAW,
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE NOR-CAL
CARPENTERS UNION,
AND DANNY CURTIN, DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS.
BOTH OF THEM ARE AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
UH, HONOR TO BE HERE.
>> UH, CHAIR SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS
AND HONOURABLE SENATORS.
UH, I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND OUR BROTHER IN THIS
STRUGGLE.
UH, ASSEMBLYMAN HANEY.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL.
UM, IN A NUTSHELL, IT'S NO
SECRET
TO ANYONE IN THIS ROOM.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE'RE
FACING IN CALIFORNIA, IT'S TOP
OF THE LIST.
UH, YOU KNOW, WE LITERALLY,
RIGHT NEED MILLIONS OF HOMES,
PARTICULARLY IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARENA
AND ULTRA AFFORDABLE, UM, WHAT'S
HAPPENING,
THOUGH, THROUGHOUT THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY
THAT ISN'T TALKED ABOUT ENOUGH,
I WOULD ARGUE, IS WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THE WORKFORCE ITSELF.
SO RESIDENTIAL OVERALL, YOU'RE
TALKING
ABOUT UPWARDS OF 300,000
WORKERS, 90% OF WHICH ARE HYPER
EXPLOITED IN OUR STATE.
UNDERNEATH THAT, THERE'S A $5
BILLION PRICE TAG TO THAT.
AND THIS IS BEING CONSERVATIVE.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE
REFER TO
AS THE CRIME SCENE OF
PRODUCTION,
INCLUDING IN PROJECTS THAT ARE
OFTEN
SUPPORTED BY LIGHT TECH FUNDS,
PUBLIC FUNDS OF WAGE THEFT,
AND NOW CASES THAT OUR OWN TEAMS
ARE BRINGING
FORWARD AROUND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OF WORKERS INTO THESE JOB SITES.
SO THIS IS ON OFTEN THE PUBLIC
DOLLAR,
WHICH IS UPWARDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS
OVER THE LAST 3 TO 4 YEARS IN
FUNDS.
AND NOW IT LOOKS LIKE IT'LL BE.
AND WE'RE WORKING TO SUPPORT
THIS TWO REGULAR
FUNDING OF ABOUT HALF A BILLION
A YEAR TOWARDS THAT AND TOWARDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
WHICH WE SUPPORT.
BUT IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE PULL
WORKERS UP.
AND THESE ARE PRIMARILY
IMMIGRANT WORKERS,
FOLKS OF COLOR IN THAT INDUSTRY.
AND WE NEED ANOTHER 100,000
RESIDENTIAL WORKERS TO MOVE
FORWARD
AND BUILD THE HOUSING THE
CALIFORNIA
SO DESPERATELY NEEDS.
SO A COUPLE OF THINGS HERE.
LET'S PULL THE WORKERS UP.
LET'S BUILD MORE HOUSING.
THIS WILL KEEP TAX DOLLARS AND
RESOURCES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES,
AND IT WILL HELP US ATTRACT A
NEW WORKFORCE.
AND IT'LL BE A WIN WIN.
AND ACTUALLY, WHAT THE STATE AND
THE COUNTIES
AND THE CITIES WILL GAIN IS THEY
WILL CAPTURE
MORE TAX DOLLARS BY BRINGING
PREVAILING WAGES
AND RIGHTS FOR THOSE WORKERS
ON THE JOB.
SO WE PLEAD FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS,
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO GET IT
DONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UM, JUST TO ADD ON A LITTLE BIT
TO WHAT JAY SAID.
HELLO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN, SENATOR.
UM.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GROWING ON
A BILL
THAT WAS PASSED OVER 20 YEARS
AGO.
WHICH BASIS?
IT'S THE FOUNDATION FOR IT IS
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
INTERVENES IN THE MARKETPLACE
BY EITHER MONEY OR BENEFITS THAT
ARE EQUIVALENT OF MONEY.
IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
ONE SIMPLE INTERVENTION.
ALMOST 100 YEARS AGO, THE
BEGINNING
OF PREVAILING WAGES
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
STARTED WITH THAT PREMISE.
IT WAS DURING THE DEPRESSION
AND WHEN THE GOVERNMENT WAS
INTERVENING IN BUILDING
BASICALLY INFRASTRUCTURE,
THEY DECIDED THAT THE WORKERS
NEEDED TO BE TAKEN CARE.
CARE CARED OF, CARE OF, AND
INSTITUTED
PREVAILING WAGES.
THAT'S BEEN THE LAW FOR ALMOST
100 YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME EXEMPTIONS
AND SOME LOOPHOLES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS IN.
20 YEARS AGO IN CALIFORNIA,
WE EXPANDED THE DEFINITION
OF PUBLIC FUNDS TO INCLUDE LOW
INTEREST LOANS,
CHEAP LAND VALUE OF LAND,
ANYTHING THAT WAS THE EQUIVALENT
OF MONEY.
THERE WAS A FEW THINGS THAT GOT
MISSED.
THIS WAS ONE, AND IT COULDN'T
BE NEEDED
MORE THAN NOW THAN EVER IN THE
PAST.
EQUIVALENT TO THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
BY THE WAY, THE WORKFORCE IS
DESPERATE.
HALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE IN
THE HOUSING INDUSTRY IS EITHER
LOW WAGE,
VERY LOW WAGE OR EXTREMELY LOW
WAGE IN POVERTY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BUILDING HOMES
THAT THEY CAN'T,
AFFORDABLE HOMES THAT THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE IN.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING HOPEFULLY,
IS CORRECTING THAT COMPLETE
PROBLEM.
AND THE HOUSING CRISIS, AS WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER,
IS MORE THAN JUST THE PRICE OF
HOUSING.
I MEAN, WITH THE LOW WAGES IN
THE INDUSTRY,
YOU WOULD THINK THE PRICES
WOULDN'T BE HIGH.
THEY'RE HIGH HAS NOTHING TO
DO REALLY WITH THOSE WAGES.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS LIFT
THE WAGES,
AS JAY SAID,
MAKE THOSE PEOPLE HOMEOWNERS
BRING
THAT WHOLE INDUSTRY UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MR.
CURTAIN.
WE HAVE NOW MID TWOS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MIKE WEST, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR SCOTT, GOVERNOR,
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
MARTIN VENDIOLA, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL,
AND THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
OF
SHEET METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL?
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME, I JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE CARPENTERS WHO SHOWED UP
TODAY,
AND A LOT OF THEM TOOK TIME OFF
WORK TO I COULD MAYBE JUST SAY,
HEY, WE'LL DO A GROUP.
ME TOO.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WITH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SPEAKING
AGAINST THE BILL TODAY?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> THANK YOU, SENATORS MARK
STIVERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP.
I THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THE BENEFITS OF PREVAILING
WAGES.
PAYING WORKERS MORE IS A GOOD
THING,
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE COST.
SO UC BERKELEY HAS STUDIED THE
IMPACT OF
PREVAILING WAGES ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING,
AND FOUND THAT IT INCREASED
DEVELOPMENT
COSTS BY ABOUT 14%,
THAT THAT NUMBER IS ACTUALLY
HIGHER.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT RURAL AND
INLAND
AREAS WHERE THERE'S LESS, UH,
THERE ARE FEWER PREVAILING WAGE
CONTRACTORS
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE WORK.
AND WITH THAT INCREASE IN COST,
IT WILL ACTUALLY DRIVE DOWN
HOUSING PRODUCTION,
BECAUSE THE HOUSING FUNDS THAT
WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ARE DWINDLING.
THE STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
EXPENDED.
THE BUDGET DOESN'T HAVE A WHOLE
LOT FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE'RE UNLIKELY TO GET ANOTHER
HOUSING BOND.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN A 38%
REDUCTION IN AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE LAST
YEAR ALONE,
AND WE WILL IF WE HAVE TO SPEND
MORE ON EACH DEVELOPMENT,
WE WILL SEE FEWER UNITS BUILT
NEXT YEAR SIGNIFICANTLY.
SO THIS IS NOT EXACTLY A WIN
WIN SITUATION.
WE WILL BE PAYING HIGHER WAGES
FOR WORKERS,
BUT WE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE FEWER
JOBS
BECAUSE THERE ARE FEWER
DEVELOPMENTS
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY PROCEED
WITH.
WE COME WITH AN OPPOSING, LESS
AMENDED POSITION.
WE UNDERSTAND.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
THAT AS WE INCREASE WAGES,
WE ALSO INCREASE THE RESOURCES
THAT
ALLOW US TO AT LEAST MAINTAIN,
IF NOT INCREASE, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
SO THIS BILL IS LINKED WITH AB
3160 BY MR.
GABRIEL.
THAT WOULD LOCK IN THE STATE
HOUSING
CREDITS FOR FIVE YEARS.
THOSE WOULD BE RESOURCES WE
CURRENTLY
AREN'T GUARANTEED.
SO WE WOULD BE WILLING TO ACCEPT
THE PREVAILING
WAGES REQUIREMENT WITH THOSE
NEW RESOURCES.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE PARTS OF
THE BILL THAT GO BEYOND THE
ENHANCED
STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS
AND APPLY THE DEVELOPMENTS,
APPLY THE PREVAILING WAGE
STANDARD TO BELOW MARKET
RATE LOANS AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS.
SO WE ARE HOPING THAT THE
CONSIDER THE COMMITTEE
WOULD CONSIDER THOSE AMENDMENTS.
WITH THAT, WE COULD BE NEUTRAL.
AND I JUST ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
I WAS ALSO HERE 20 YEARS
AGO WHEN THE WHEN THE CURRENT
LAW WAS STIPULATED,
AND I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THINGS
WERE LEFT
OUT OR THAT THESE WERE
LOOPHOLES,
THAT PREVAILING WAGE LAW THAT
EXISTS
TODAY WAS METICULOUSLY
NEGOTIATED,
AND EVERYTHING THAT WAS IN THERE
WAS
SORT OF PART OF THE NEGOTIATION.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, 20
YEARS LATER,
THE LEGISLATURE IS FREE TO
REVISIT THAT.
BUT IT WAS NOT THESE THINGS WERE
NOT LEFT OUT ON PURPOSE.
THIS IS MY LAST POINT.
BUT ANYWAY, WE LOOK FOR YOUR WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THE CARPENTERS TO GET TO
A AN AGREEMENT HERE ON THIS.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
X WITNESS.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
>> JUST A ME TOO, MA'AM.
UH, STEPHEN CENSER, WITH
BROWNSTEIN,
ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE, MR.
STIVERS, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO RESOLVE THIS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, SO WE'RE TAKING ME TO
STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
>> UH, MARINA ESPINOSA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM,
ALSO WITH AN OPPOSING LAST
AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> MELANIE PERRIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
WE WILL MOVE TO THE DAIS,
SENATOR.
>> YEAH.
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND THE SPONSORS
AS WELL.
AND TO THE OPPOSITION.
I SUSPECT THIS IS GOING TO GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE.
I'M CERTAINLY A SUPPORTER, AND
I'D BE HAPPY
TO TO MOVE THE ITEM TO THE
OPPOSITION.
I THINK SOMETIMES, UH,
SOMETIMES WHEN GOOD COMMENTS ARE
MADE LIKE THAT,
IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THEM,
THE OPPOSITION WILL FEEL
UNHEARD.
UM, AND I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT,
UM, BOTH ARE NEEDED.
THIS IS A BOTH AND SITUATION
AND WE ARE WOEFULLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
AND TAX CREDITS.
UM, WE NEED MORE, A LOT MORE.
I THINK WE NEED CREDIT
ENHANCEMENT.
I THINK THE STATE'S ITS OWN
CREDIT RATING SHOULD
BE USED TO TO HELP FINANCE
PROJECTS.
UM, AND I THINK WE NEED MORE
SUBSIDIES IN GENERAL.
AND ALL OF THAT IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT SHOULD
BE CARRIED IN OTHER LEGISLATION
AND IN BUDGET ACTIONS AND NOT
AMENDED ONTO THIS BILL.
UM, BECAUSE WHAT WE CAN'T DO IS
DO ALL OF THAT.
I'M GOING TO TURN THE TABLES,
DO ALL OF THAT,
AND THEN HAVE PEOPLE WORKING ON
THESE PROJECTS
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO MOVE INTO
THEM.
SO WE HAVE TO JUST TAKE THESE
THINGS SEPARATELY SOMETIMES.
I DO AGREE IT'S A GOOD TIME
TO BRING THESE THINGS UP.
I MEAN, WE'RE HAVING A HEARING.
EVERYONE SHOULD SPEAK THEIR
PIECE
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT ELSE IS
NEEDED.
UM, THIS IS JUST ONE PIECE
THAT'S NEEDED,
AND IT'S A PIECE THAT WE WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD TODAY.
AND AGAIN, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WE WILL MOVE IT, UH,
FOR OUR MOTION AS SOON AS WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS,
SENATOR CORTEZ,
AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THIS BILL.
UM, IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE TO HAVE
WORKERS
BUILD SOMETHING LIKE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THEN NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFORD TO LIVE IN IT.
AND I THINK WE DO IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE THAT,
UM, WORKERS ARE, ARE PROTECTED,
UM,
THAT WAGES ARE INCREASING SO
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
AFFORD THE COST OF HOUSING IN
THIS GREAT STATE.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS ABOUT
BREAKING
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
WE THANK YOU FOR THIS.
AND WE'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND I DO WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE FOLKS FROM THE OPPOSITION.
OBVIOUSLY, WE ALL HAVE TO DO
THIS TOGETHER.
THOSE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
WHO ARE LEADING THESE PROJECTS,
AND THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
ROOM,
WHO ARE LITERALLY USING THEIR
HANDS
TO BUILD THESE PROJECTS.
WE DO WANT TO MAKE THIS A WIN
WIN.
THIS BILL IS NOW TIED TO MR.
GABRIEL'S BILL THAT HAS
AN ANNUAL $500 MILLION IN IT.
SO WE MAKE SURE THERE'S
RESOURCES.
WE MAKE SURE THOSE RESOURCES ARE
USED NOT ONLY TO BUILD HOUSING,
BUT TO MAKE SURE WE PAY THE
FOLKS
ENOUGH SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND HAVE HOUSING THEMSELVES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR US TO
USE PUBLIC DOLLARS,
PAY SUCH A LOW RATE TO WORKERS
THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES,
AND THEN WE HAVE TO STEP IN WITH
ADDITIONAL STATE RESOURCES.
I DO HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND MAKE SURE
THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE FOR THESE
WORKERS AND ALSO EXPAND THE
LEVEL
OF RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE,
WHICH I, WE WOULD ALL AGREE ARE
FAR TOO FEW.
WITH THAT, AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME,
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY.
AND, UM, I WAS JUST REMINDED
THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS YET TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM,
SO MY MOTION WILL HAVE TO WAIT.
BUT WE WILL, UM, OBVIOUSLY
RESPECTFULLY
CONSIDER THE ITEM.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE
CAN TAKE UP VOTING.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE ALL THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
AND, UM.
I'M DOING ALL THIS TALKING
BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN DRAFTED INTO CHAIRING,
BUT I'M GOING TO TALK A LOT LESS
WHILE I'M CHAIRING.
AND.
OUR ESTEEMED CHAIR WILL BE BACK
SOON AFTER
SHE'S DONE PRESENTING A COUPLE
OF BILLS.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN, AB
2335.
JUST FOLLOWING THE FOLLOW ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIR.
>> I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB 2335,
WHICH IS SPONSORED BY EXCUSE ME,
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION
OF PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS,
UNITED AUTO WORKERS.
THE THIS BILL MANDATES THE STATE
TO UPHOLD
OR REINSTATE THE HISTORICAL
SALARY
PARITY AMONG STATE CIVIL SERVICE
CLASSIFICATION
AND BARGAINING UNITS,
ENSURING THAT COMPARABLE
COMPENSATION IS PROVIDED
FOR ROLES THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
ALIKE.
MOREOVER, IT REQUIRES THE STATE
TO RECTIFY ANY
GENDER BASED WAGE DISPARITY AND
MAY PERSIST
BETWEEN CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS
AND CLASSIFICATIONS
THAT PERFORM SIMILAR DUTIES.
STATE SCIENTISTS SALARIES LAG
THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS,
AND OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES THAT
DO SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR WORK BY UPWARDS OF 40%.
THIS IS INCONSISTENT WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S
DECLARED PRIORITY
OF ESTABLISHING EQUITY AS
THE STATE'S LARGEST EMPLOYER.
IT'S CRITICAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE AND WORK TO
CREATE
A CALIFORNIA WHERE ALL EMPLOYEES
ARE VALUED
AND RESPECTED AND PAID
EQUITABLY.
PROVIDING EQUITABLE PAY IS
ESSENTIAL
FOR PROMOTING GENDER EQUALITY,
ATTRACTING AND RETAINING STATE
EMPLOYEES,
AND ENHANCING THE STATE'S
ABILITY
TO BE THE EMPLOYER OF CHOICE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF
OF THE BILL IS HANNAH JOHNSON,
REPRESENTING CAPS, UAW.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE'LL HAVE A COUPLE OF MINUTES,
OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
AND OR WHEN THE CHAIR RETURNS.
AND MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
MY NAME IS HANNAH JOHNSON, AND
I'M A RESEARCH
SCIENTIST WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO
THE SECRETARY OF UAW LOCAL 1115.
UM, WHICH IS THE UNION FOR
CALIFORNIA
STATE SCIENTISTS.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER
MCKINNON FOR HER UNWAVERING
SUPPORT OF STATE SCIENTISTS,
AND FOR SPONSORING AB 2335.
I WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS BEHALF
OF THIS BILL BY LETTING YOU
ALL KNOW THAT WE ARE LOSING
CALIFORNIA
STATE SCIENTISTS,
STATE SCIENTISTS THAT HELP MAKE
UP THE BEDROCK
OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE,
INCLUDING PANDEMIC RESPONSE,
WHO MONITOR AND REGULATE
INDUSTRIAL POLLUTERS,
WHO CLEAN UP OIL SPILLS
AND MITIGATE WILDFIRE DAMAGE,
WHO KEEP OUR FOOD AND DRINKING
WATER SAFE AND CLEAN.
WE ARE LOSING STATE SCIENTISTS
AT A TIME WHEN SCIENCE
IS THE KEY TO MITIGATING CLIMATE
DISASTERS.
WE'RE LOSING THEM TO COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS,
TO CITY GOVERNMENTS.
WE'RE LOSING THEM TO PRIVATE
INDUSTRY
AND TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
ALL WHO PAY MORE COMPETITIVE
WAGES
THAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MOST SHOCKINGLY, WE'RE
LOSING
THEM TO THE GENDER PAY GAP
THAT EXISTS WITHIN OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT,
WHERE EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
IS NOT BEING HONORED,
AND WHERE HISTORICAL PAY
STRUCTURES
ARE BEING IGNORED.
THIS HAS LED TO STATE
SCIENTISTS,
WHO ARE PREDOMINANTLY NON MALE
BARGAINING UNIT,
TO BE COMPENSATED AT A RATE
OF UP
TO 40% LESS THAN STATE
ENGINEERS,
A PREDOMINANTLY MALE BARGAINING
UNIT,
FOR THE EXACT SAME WORK AND FOR
WORK THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY COMPARABLY
VALUED.
THIS HAS FORCED MANY STATE
SCIENTISTS
TO LEAVE THE SCIENTIFIC
BARGAINING UNIT FOR THE
ENGINEERING ONE.
THE STATE HAS ALREADY ADDRESSED
THIS INJUSTICE
FOR OUR SCIENTIFIC SUPERVISORS
AND MANAGERS,
YET REFUSES TO DO SO FOR RANK
AND FILE EMPLOYEES.
AB 2335 WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
TO RESTORE
AND MAINTAIN THESE HISTORIC
SALARY RELATIONSHIPS
THAT EXISTED BETWEEN RANK AND
FILE STATE
SCIENTISTS AND STATE ENGINEERS.
THIS WILL ALSO HELP CLOSE THE
GENDER PAY
INEQUITIES THAT EXIST WITHIN
STATE
CIVIL SERVICE JOBS AND
CLASSIFICATIONS
THAT ARE PERFORMING LIKE WORK.
AS THE STATE'S LARGEST EMPLOYER.
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON
SAID
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LEADS BY EXAMPLE AND
STANDS
BY ITS OWN STATED VALUES.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT AB 2335 AND
HELP ENSURE THAT
STATE WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY
AND EQUITABLY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COME FORWARD AND EXPRESS A
SUPPORT POSITION?
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ESTHER TRACY.
I AM WITH CAPS, UAW LOCAL 1115
AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
>> MY NAME IS SARAH KEELER AND
I'M WITH CAPS,
UAW LOCAL 1115,
AND I AM ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
>> JUSTIN GARCIA, UAW LOCAL
1115, IN SUPPORT.
>> TOM HINCHEY ON BEHALF OF THE
UAW IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NOW WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON THIS BILL?
SEEING NONE COME FORWARD, IS
THERE ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME?
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD,
WE'LL COME BACK HERE TO THE
DAIS.
SENATOR WILK.
SURE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT.
I KNOW WE HAVE CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF RETAINING EMPLOYEES
WHEN IT COMES TO IT AND
OBVIOUSLY
THE SCIENCE SCIENCES.
I HAD NO I THOUGHT WE HAD FIXED
THIS PROBLEM A LONG TIME AGO.
I KNOW IN THE SENATE IT WAS
BEFORE WE GOT HERE,
BUT THERE WAS GENDER INEQUITY
AND THAT THAT
WAS ADDRESSED LIKE 9 OR 10 YEARS
AGO.
SO I'M KIND OF SHOCKED THAT
THIS HAS GONE ON THIS LONG.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF YOUR BILL TODAY
AND HAPPY TO MOVE IT WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
UM, SOME MEMBER WILL GIVE YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD, WE HAVE
AN HAVE
NOT ESTABLISHED A QUORUM YET,
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE
A STRONG MOTION IN WAITING,
SO WE'LL GET TO THAT WHEN WE
CAN.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE NOW.
THANK YOU.
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PAY OUR SCIENTISTS,
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT CLIMATE
CHANGE,
AS WE LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
TO OUR STATE.
WE DON'T NEED TO LOSE
SCIENTISTS.
WE NEED THEM THERE.
SO I'M URGING AND ASKING FOR
YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZUBER ON ITEM 12 AB 2889.
WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
MEMBER.
UM, I'M PROUD TODAY TO PRESENT
AB 2889,
A MEASURE THAT MAKES RESOLVING
LABOR DISPUTES MORE EFFICIENT,
EFFECTIVE, AND FAIR WITHIN LOS
ANGELES
COUNTY AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS,
SEIU CALIFORNIA, AND AFSCME
CALIFORNIA.
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BOARD, OR PERB,
CURRENTLY HAS OVERSIGHT
JURISDICTION
OVER DISPUTES BETWEEN ALMOST
ALL PUBLIC AGENCY EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER, CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WITH A LOCAL ALTERNATIVE
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
THE LOS ANGELES LOCAL
ALTERNATIVE HAS THE POWER
TO INVESTIGATE UNFAIR PRACTICE
CHARGES,
DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE CHARGES
ARE JUSTIFIED,
AND, IF SO, PRESCRIBE
APPROPRIATE REMEDIES.
THE STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO
THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES GIVE
EMPLOYERS
AN UNFAIR LEVERAGE THAT IS NOT
PRESENT
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
THIS MEANS THAT UNIONS THAT
BARGAIN
WITH THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES ARE THE ONLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE UNIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT
AFFORDED
TO THE SAME EXTENT OF
PROTECTIONS
THAT OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
UNIONS
OBTAIN THROUGH PERB.
A BIT OF HISTORY.
IN 2011, THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
PROTECTIONS
TO PROHIBIT UNION BUSTING,
WHICH WITHIN THE JURISDICTION
OF PERB THAT YEAR.
SB 857 PROHIBITED PER FROM
AWARDING STRIKE
PREPARATION EXPENSES AS DAMAGES
FOR AN UNFAIR FROM AN UNLAWFUL
STRIKE
DUE TO THE DRAFT A DRAFTING
ERROR.
THE EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ENTITIES
IN THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES WERE NOT EXPRESSLY
IDENTIFIED IN THE LAW,
WHICH MEANS THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS MAY NOT
APPLY TO UNIONS UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION.
MANY OF THE ACTIVITIES WORKERS
ROUTINELY ENGAGE IN DURING
A CONTRACT CONTRACT CAMPAIGN,
SUCH AS MEMBERSHIP RALLIES,
WEARING UNION BUTTONS,
OR PARTICIPATING IN A STRIKE
AUTHORIZATION VOTE,
COULD BE USED TO JUSTIFY THESE
DAMAGES.
HOWEVER, I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE
THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN
IS NOT MEANINGFUL IF WORKERS
CANNOT
ENGAGE IN CONCERTED ACTIVITIES.
THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
ALIGNING
LABOR PRACTICES ACROSS THE
STATE,
IT'S ALSO ABOUT FAIRNESS FOR
ALL PUBLIC
AND PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AB 2889 PROVIDES PERB WITH
EXCLUSIVE
INITIAL JURISDICTION OVER
REQUESTS
FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF BY BOTH
THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES,
JUST AS IT ALREADY HAS FOR ALL
ALREADY
HAS FOR OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES THAT THE LOCAL
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
ENTITIES AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO
AWARD DAMAGES RESULTING FROM
A STRIKE.
THIS ENSURES THAT LOCAL PUBLIC
SECTOR UNIONS IN
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LA HAVE
THE SAME PROTECTION FROM
UNION BUSTING TACTICS THAT OTHER
UNIONS UNDER PERB
JURISDICTION HAVE ENJOYED FOR
OVER A DECADE.
I ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE JANICE
O'MALLEY,
REPRESENTING SB CALIFORNIA AND
GEORGE OSBORNE,
REPRESENTING UPD.
WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE THE ORIGINAL SPONSORS OF
SENATE BILL 857 13 YEARS AGO,
ALONG WITH AFSCME LOCAL 3299,
REPRESENTING UC WORKERS, UH,
AUTHORED BY THEN SENATOR,
NOW CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU,
TO PROTECT EVERY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
IN CALIFORNIA
FROM ATTACKS ON OUR RIGHT
TO STRIKE AND SAVING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS
IN FALSE AND FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS.
THE LAW WAS CREATED TO PROTECT
ALL
UNIONS FROM UNION BUSTING
TACTICS,
AS THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN IS
IMPAIRED WHEN WORKERS ARE
DISSUADED
UNDER THREAT OF EXORBITANT
DAMAGES FROM
ENGAGING IN CONCERTED
ACTIVITIES.
THE PREMISE THAT AN EMPLOYER
IS ENTITLED
TO STRIKE PREPARATION DAMAGES,
INCLUDING WHERE NO ACTUAL STRIKE
OCCURRED,
DIRECTLY INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY OF WORKERS
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW.
WHEN AFSCME SPONSORED SENATE
BILL EIGHT FIVE 7 IN 2011,
THE ASSUMPTION WAS THAT IT WOULD
COVER ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND THOSE UNDER THE MYERS MILIUS
BROWN ACT,
THE ACT THAT ESTABLISHES
BARGAINING
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MUNICIPAL,
COUNTY, AND LOCAL SPECIAL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES.
YOU SEE, THE BILL, UH, THAT WAS
PASSED IN 2011.
IT WAS BEFORE A COURT OF APPEAL
DECISION
ESTABLISHED PERB IN THE MBA,
BUT IT FAILED TO IDENTIFY IRCAM
AND HERB LA HERB,
AND THEREFORE IT IS A LEGALLY
LEFT UNCLEAR WHETHER
BOTH THOSE ENTITIES EMPLOYEES
IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LA HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS AS THEIR UNION,
SIBLINGS AND OTHER MEMBER
JURISDICTIONS.
THEREFORE, WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 2089
TO FOR THE SAME STRIKE
PREPARATION RIGHTS
TO LA CITY AND LA COUNTY
EMPLOYEES AS ALL OTHER
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES
CURRENTLY ENJOY.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE.
>> UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
UH, GEORGE OSBORNE FOR THE UNION
OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND DENTIST CO-SPONSOR FOR
STRONG SUPPORT.
AND, OF COURSE, AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS,
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER THEM.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
UM, WE CAN NOW OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANYONE WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL,
PLEASE COME FORWARD AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU, SANDRA BURR ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA
PROUD CO-SPONSORS AND SUPPORT.
HELLO, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
JUAN FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE COME FORWARD,
WE'LL MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION WITNESS
IN THE ROOM?
IF SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND SEEN NO SUCH PERSON.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PUBLICLY EXPRESS
SUPPORT?
IF SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME.
I'M.
I'M SORRY.
OPPOSITION WE DID SUPPORT.
SO, LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
AND SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD,
WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
NOTHING FROM SENATOR WILK.
I WOULD JUST THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND WE'RE STRUGGLING TO GET
OUR QUORUM TOGETHER HERE.
AND AS SOON AS WE DO, WE'LL MOVE
ON YOUR BILL.
AND JUST THANK YOU ALL FOR
CONSIDERING THE BILL.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR YOUR VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU.
UH, LET ME JUST NOTE THAT WE
HAVE
MADE IT THROUGH THE AGENDA.
UH, WE DO OBVIOUSLY HAVE ITEMS
TO MOVE
AND VOTE ON UP AND DOWN THE
AGENDA.
EXCEPT FOR ITEM FIVE, WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY'S BILL.
AND IF SOMEBODY KNOWS HIS
WHEREABOUTS.
WE SLIP HIM A NOTE AND ASK HIM
TO COME ON OVER.
WE'D LIKE TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
GET HIM
THROUGH THE PROCESS HERE RIGHT
AWAY.
WITH THAT, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE RECESS
AND HOPE THAT HE APPEARS DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND I'M GOING TO OFFICIALLY
RECESS.
UH, UNTIL WE COME BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WELCOME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU NEED TIME
FOR WITNESSES
OR IF YOU'RE READY TO COME TO
THE PODIUM.
IF SO, I'M GOING TO RECONVENE.
WE MAY NEED 30S TO LIFT THE
RECESS.
SO.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
WILL RECONVENE AT THIS TIME,
AND WE'LL GIVE OUR AUDIO 30
MINUTES
TO COME ON 30S, NOT 30 MINUTES.
HOPE WE WON'T BE HERE IN 30
MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE READY TO GO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SEE YOU HERE.
WELCOME.
OKAY.
YOU CAN PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU.
UM, THIS IS A BILL THAT YOU
MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH FROM LAST YEAR.
OTHER POLICY COMMITTEES.
UM, IT DIDN'T PASS LAST YEAR.
UM.
IT WAS VETOED, BUT WE TOOK
A LOOK AT THE VETO MESSAGE
AND WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION,
THE OPPOSITION.
AND ATTEMPTED TO TO CLARIFY AND
ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS.
AND I KNOW WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE
WITH SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION WE'LL HEAR
FROM AGAIN.
BUT WE THINK THAT WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY REALLY BOILS
DOWN TO THE SIMPLE ISSUE OF IN
OUR DISTRICTS,
WHERE WE HAVE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES,
WHETHER THEY BE FROM A K 12
DISTRICT
OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE WORK IN
PART TIME JOBS,
AND SOME OF THE SOME JOB
OPENINGS COME OPEN.
OTHER PART TIME JOBS.
AND, YOU KNOW, MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS
WORK PART TIME, LET'S SAY,
AS THE BUS DRIVER DURING THE
MORNING
SHIFT AND THE AFTERNOON SHIFT,
AND THEY MAY HAVE TO GO WORK
OTHER JOBS,
OTHER SOMETIMES FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY,
OTHER MINIMUM WAGE JOBS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T
GET ENOUGH HOURS TO PAY A LIVING
WAGE.
AND THE CONCEPT OF THIS IS IS
NOT THAT COMPLICATED.
IT SAYS IF THERE'S A JOB OPENING
ON THE CAMPUS.
SO THE HYPOTHETICAL WE USE IS
IF THERE'S
A LUNCHROOM AIDE AND THERE'S
A BUS DRIVER THAT DOES THE
MORNING BUS
SHIFT AND THE AFTERNOON BUS
SHIFT,
AND, HEY, MAYBE THEY CAN DO
THE LUNCH SHIFT IN THE MIDDLE.
LET'S GIVE THEM, UH, THE RIGHT,
THE FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL FOR
THIS JOB OPENING.
UH, ALL OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE HAVING
AN EDUCATOR WORKFORCE SHORTAGE,
NOT JUST IN TEACHERS WE KNOW
ABOUT,
BUT CLERICAL MAINTENANCE, FOOD
OPERATIONS,
COMPUTER SERVICES,
CLASSROOM AIDES, AS WELL AS BUS
DRIVERS.
AND IT'S TOUGH TO TO HAVE PEOPLE
SPLIT
BETWEEN THESE TWO PART TIME
JOBS,
BECAUSE LET'S FACE IT, WITH,
YOU KNOW,
RISING COSTS AND FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SO FORTH,
WHO WANTS TO WORK MULTIPLE, UM,
PART TIME JOBS.
AND SO THERE ARE QUALIFIED
WORKERS OUT THERE,
AND MANY TIMES THEY'RE RIGHT
UNDER YOUR OWN NOSE.
AND SO WE THINK THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER A FAIR,
BALANCED APPROACH WHERE NO
ADDITIONAL,
UM, YOU KNOW, LIMIT THE TIME
EXTENSION ON THIS.
UM, BUT GIVE THE WORKERS WHO ARE
ALREADY ON,
ON THE CAMPUS AND THESE
DISTRICTS THE FIRST CRACK
TO APPLY AND GAIN EMPLOYMENT FOR
THESE POSITIONS.
UM, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
AND WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CSCA AS WELL
AS CFT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME.
YOU CAN BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF MINUTES
EACH.
SURE.
I'LL BE QUICK.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS, MATT
BROUGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF CSCA.
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
SUMMED IT UP PERFECTLY.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED
THE BILL
TO ADDRESS OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
PROBABLY,
AS FAR AS WE CAN TAKE IT,
YOU KNOW, WITHOUT COMPROMISING
THE THE SPIRIT OF THE BILL.
WE'VE MADE VERY SURE TO BE
DEFERENTIAL
TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AND WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT THIS
RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL IS REALLY THE
FLOOR IF,
UH, IF, UH, EDUCATION EMPLOYERS
WANT
TO BARGAIN AROUND PROVISIONS,
THEY'RE CERTAINLY WELCOME TO
AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM TO FINALLY,
JUST AS AN ANECDOTAL NOTE, UH,
THIS THIS CAN ALREADY HAPPEN.
IT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN SEVERAL
SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
UM, WE IMPLEMENTED IT IN THE BAY
AREA DURING
COVID AT I'M THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
EVADES ME,
BUT THEY WENT FROM HAVING 46
PARAEDUCATOR OPENINGS
TO LESS THAN SIX FROM 2020 TO
2024.
UH, AND IF THAT ISN'T PROOF THAT
THIS WORKS TO SORT
OF ADDRESS THAT THAT EDUCATION
WORKER SHORTFALL,
I'M NOT SURE WHAT ELSE WOULD.
SO WITH THAT, UM, I ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS AND STAFF MITCH STEIGER
WITH CFT,
A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS,
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL
ALONG WITH CSEA,
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED SO
WELL BY
THE AUTHOR AND PREVIOUS WITNESS,
WE WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE SEE
THIS AS
A PRETTY IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
SIGN
OF RESPECT FOR OUR CLASSIFIED
MEMBERS
AND ALL OF THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS.
THEY LOVE WHAT THEY DO, AND
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND FOR
WEEKS OR MONTHS OR YEARS, OR
SOMETIMES DECADES.
DESPITE THE DEMANDS AND DESPITE
THE OFTEN RELATIVELY
LOW PAY THAT THEY EARN BECAUSE
THEY LIKE BEING
A FOUNDATION OF THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND THEY LIKE
BEING ABLE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN STUDENTS LIVES.
BUT WHEN THEY SEE THEIR HOURS
BEING KEPT LOW AND MANY
OTHER PART TIME JOBS BEING
CREATED AROUND THEM,
IT'S ONE MORE THING THAT MAKES
IT HARDER TO KEEP THEM THERE.
AND EVENTUALLY, YOU KNOW, IF IT
GETS BAD ENOUGH,
THEY WILL LEAVE AND THEY WILL
GO FIND OTHER EMPLOYMENT.
WE LOSE THOSE YEARS, WE LOSE
THAT EXPERIENCE.
WE LOSE THAT DEDICATION AND THAT
LOVE FOR THE JOB.
AND SO THIS IS A BIG STEP IN
THE DIRECTION
OF KEEPING THOSE FOLKS THERE,
KEEPING THE STUDENTS AND
EVERYONE
THERE WHERE WE CAN BENEFIT
FROM WHAT THEY KNOW AND WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED.
AND SO WE THINK NOT ONLY IS IT
THE RIGHT
THING TO DO FOR THESE WORKERS,
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND KEEPING
THE RIGHT PEOPLE THERE ON THE
JOB,
KEEPING THAT EXPERIENCE THERE.
AND WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO COME FORWARD
AND EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION
MAY DO SO NOW.
>> TIFFANY WHITE AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE,
YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JENNA SIMPLY ASKED ME.
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
OH, RIGHT.
THAT LOOKS LIKE.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR SUPPORT.
UM, WITNESSES, IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION HERE TO TESTIFY?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU'LL HAVE A COUPLE OF MINUTES
EACH.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LAURA LILLY AND I
AM WITH
THE PLACER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 2088,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS,
REPRESENTING 30,000 SCHOOL
BUSINESS
LEADERS STATEWIDE.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
INTENTIONS OF AB 2088 TO
IMPROVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF,
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
MEASURE.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPEDE THE LEA'S
ABILITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
EXPEDIENTLY HIRE EMPLOYEES BEST
SUITED FOR OUR STUDENTS NEEDS.
AB 2088 WOULD LENGTHEN VACANCIES
AND WE ARE
ALREADY EXPERIENCING STAFFING
SHORTAGES,
AS WAS MENTIONED, ESPECIALLY IN
THE CLASSROOM
PARAPROFESSIONAL POSITIONS.
MANY OF THOSE POSITIONS SERVE
OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO HAVE INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLANS, OR IEPS,
AND WE ARE LEGALLY BOUND TO
PROVIDE
THOSE IMPORTANT SERVICES
TO OUR STUDENTS IMMEDIATELY AND
CONTINUOUSLY.
DURING THE PROPOSED TEN DAY WAIT
PERIOD FOR INTERNAL APPLICANTS.
FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL.
WE MAY BE LUCKY AND WE MIGHT
FIND A SUBSTITUTE,
BUT MORE THAN LIKELY WE NEED
TO HIRE FROM AN OUTSIDE STAFFING
AGENCY
AT DOUBLE OR TRIPLE THE COST.
THERE ARE ALSO A WIDE RANGE
OF TASKS
AND COMPETENCIES REQUIRED
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS FOR THOSE
WITH
AND WITHOUT SPECIAL NEEDS.
WE NEED TO MATCH OUR STAFF SKILL
SETS TO THE STUDENT
NEEDS IN A HIGHER DATE SHOULD
NOT BE THE FACTOR.
WE BELIEVE THAT AB 2088 WILL
UNDERMINE OUR LOCAL
EFFORTS FOR DIVERSITY, EQUITY
AND INCLUSION.
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
UNDERSTAND THAT
OUR STUDENT ATTITUDES ARE
CHANGING,
AND WE WANT OUR WORKFORCE TO
REPRESENT BOTH
THE INHERENT AND ACQUIRED
DIVERSITY.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO CONSIDER
DIVERSITY OF OUR DEPARTMENTS,
OF OUR SCHOOL SITES, OR OUR
DISTRICTS AS
A WHOLE WHEN MAKING HIRING
DECISIONS.
IN CLOSING, I'D LIKE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
THE LONG TERM IMPACTS OF THIS
BILL AS WELL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE LIVED
THROUGH
THE GREAT RESIGNATION,
AND WE'VE OFTEN HAD TO LOWER
OUR MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
IN ORDER TO FILL OUR VACANCIES.
WHAT WILL THE IMPACT BE TO OUR
SCHOOLS OVER TIME?
>> CAN YOU PLEASE WRAP.
UP YOUR TIME AS.
YES.
WHAT WILL BE THE IMPACT TO OUR
SCHOOLS
ONCE SENIORITY IS THE MAIN
DRIVER?
HOW INNOVATIVE WILL CURRENT
EMPLOYEES
BE KNOWING THAT THEIR
MEANS TO PROMOTION IS BASED ON
WHEN THEY WERE HIRED,
NOT THEIR RAPPORT WITH STUDENTS
OR THEIR EXPERIENCES?
AND HOW WILL WE ATTRACT NEW
PEOPLE?
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
YES.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M ERIC ROWAN, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HUMAN
CLASSIFIED HUMAN RESOURCES FOR
THE L.A.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
UM, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS DESERVE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FROM THE
MOST QUALIFIED,
PASSIONATE, AND HARD WORKING
EMPLOYEES
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME OF HIRE.
UNFORTUNATELY, AB 2088 FAILS A
STANDARD
AND CREATES UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES
THAT WILL HARM CLASSIFIED HIRING
PROCESSES
AND IN TURN, OUR STUDENTS.
THE STATED GOAL OF THIS BILL
IS SIMPLY
TO ALLOW PART TIME CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO INCREASE THEIR
WORKING
HOURS AND RECEIVE PAID BENEFITS.
HOWEVER, THE LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU
APPLIES TO ALL PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STAFF IN UNION
REPRESENTED
POSITIONS AND LIMITING THE
DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO
FILL EVERY SINGLE VACANCY IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
IT ALSO PREVENTS THE USE OF
EQUITABLE
AND VALIDATED METHODS FOR HIRING
THE MOST
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES TO FILL
THESE ESSENTIAL
ROLES AND SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
YOU OFTEN HEAR CLASSIFIED
PERSONNEL,
DESCRIBED AS THE CUSTODIAL STAFF
AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT POSITIONS THAT SERVE AS
THE BACKBONE OF OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WHILE THAT IS 100% TRUE,
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS BILL WOULD AFFECT A WIDE
VARIETY OF POSITIONS,
INCLUDING UM, TECHNICAL ROLES
LIKE NETWORK ENGINEERS,
ACCOUNTANTS AND BUILDING
ARCHITECTS,
DIRECT SERVICE ROLES LIKE
SPECIAL EDUCATION
ASSISTANTS AND OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS,
AND EVEN SCHOOL POLICE.
THERE IS NO OTHER INDUSTRY,
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE,
WHERE THESE ESSENTIAL ROLES
WOULD BE HIRED
SOLELY BASED ON PROMOTIONAL
STATUS,
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS AND FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL
IN THE PERSONNEL COMMISSION
OFFICE.
OUR PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO UPHOLD
THE PRACTICES PRESCRIBED IN
ED CODE,
ENSURING HIRING PRACTICES ARE
CONDUCTED IN A FAIR,
EQUITABLE AND MERIT BASED
MANNER.
THE REASON I'M HERE TODAY,
AND THAT SO MANY DISTRICTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA PERSONNEL
COMMISSION ASSOCIATION,
IS BECAUSE THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION WOULD
SKIP OVER OUR PROCESSES
COMPLETELY.
UM, FOR EXAMPLE, THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE
DISTRICTS TO HIRE AND PROMOTE
BASED
ON MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR
THE POSITION
BUT OTHER EDUCATION CODE.
SO PLEASE WRAP UP.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SURE.
SO OTHER EDUCATION CODE DICTATES
THAT
THOSE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
SHOULD
BE AS LOW AS POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
A DIVERSE
GROUP OF QUALIFIED APPLICANTS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THIS, UM,
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW US TO
CONSIDER THOSE APPLICANTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SO ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
DOROTHY JOHNSON,
ON BEHALF OF ACSA,
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION,
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS, ALL OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, ANDREW
MARTINEZ,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION,
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO CITRUS
COLLEGE,
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE AND
NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF
OF THREE ORGANIZATIONS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, AND.
>> THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
>> ONEOK MEETS ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
>> BÉLA KUN ON BEHALF OF CLOVIS
UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
>> STELLA JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
REDONDO
BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION.
SIERRA COOK WITH SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
>> CHRISTINA MARSALIS ON BEHALF
OF
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION,
THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA,
AND THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
DISTRICT ADVOCATES
FOR BETTER SCHOOLS AND
OPPOSITION.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRIS REIF ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
LOOKS LIKE THAT'S IT FOR
OPPOSITION.
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE DAIS.
BUT BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD,
LET'S GET A QUORUM.
SINCE WE HAVE MEMBERS HERE.
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
HERE.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
HERE.
WILK.
PRESENT.
CORTEZ.
HERE.
DURAZO.
LAIRD.
>> WE HAVE A QUORUM.
PERFECT.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS?
SENATOR CORTESE.
LET ME JUST MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT.
UM, AGAIN, YOU KNOW, WITH WITH
OPPOSITION HERE,
WHICH I THINK HAS SINCERE
CONCERNS.
I KIND OF FALL BACK ON MY MY
SCHOOL BOARD EXPERIENCE,
WHICH WAS MANY YEARS AGO,
BUT WAS IN THE LARGEST HIGH
SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND OF COURSE, I'VE STILL BEEN
CONNECTED
THROUGH ALL MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WORK AND SENATORIAL WORK HERE
WITH
THAT DISTRICT AND MANY OTHERS.
BUT HAVING BEEN THERE AS A
SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER FOR EIGHT YEARS.
YOU KNOW, I'M.
FALLING ONCE AGAIN ON THE SIDE
OF
OF CREATING THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AND, YOU KNOW, MY HOPE IS THAT
FROM
AN ADMINISTRATIVE STANDPOINT,
THE DISTRICTS CAN FIGURE IT OUT
AND MAKE IT WORK.
I COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR, YOU
KNOW, COMING BACK,
I SUPPORTED LAST YEAR'S VERSION
OF THE BILL AND AGAIN,
CERTAINLY COMMEND HIS EFFORTS TO
TRY TO CREATE OPPORTUNITY WHERE,
YOU KNOW, THERE COULD BE
OVERSIGHTS,
THERE COULD BE, UM.
YOU KNOW, A LITTLE TREPIDATION
OR RETICENCE FOR PEOPLE TO
TO TRY TO MAKE THE LEAP INTO
THAT,
THAT OTHER POSITION.
I JUST THINK ANYTHING THAT
ENCOURAGES
THAT KIND OF, UM.
HOMEGROWN IN-HOUSE.
YOU KNOW, OFF THE BENCH KIND OF
ADVANCEMENT
IS IS TYPICALLY GOOD,
ESPECIALLY IN OUR PUBLIC SECTOR.
BUT YOU KNOW, I THINK WE ALL
KNOW IN OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE OF
THAT AS WELL,
AND LESS PART TIME AND MORE FULL
TIME WHERE WE CAN GET IT.
SO I DON'T MEAN TO, UM, I HOPE
WE HAVEN'T
MISCHARACTERIZED ANYTHING IN
THE BILL.
I JUST RECALL FROM MY, MY LOOK
AT IT THAT, UM,
THE VALUE OF ACCOMPLISHING WHAT
THE BILL IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF OUTWEIGHS
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CONCERN
FOR ME RIGHT NOW, EVEN THOUGH I
THINK IT'S VALID.
AND, UM, THEY'LL HAVE SOME
THINGS TO WORK OUT.
SO I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL,
MADAM CHAIR.
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SO WE WILL
GO TO YOU, MR.
MCCARTY, TO CLOSE.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
I, TO THE LIFE OF ME,
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS SO
COMPLICATED.
I THINK IT JUST BOILS DOWN TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WANT TO
HAVE
PEOPLE WHO WORK PART TIME
BECAUSE
THEY CAN PAY THEM LESS.
WE'LL HAVE TO PAY THEM BENEFITS.
AND THAT'S AS A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
SO WE FOCUSED ON QUALIFICATIONS.
THESE AREN'T.
THESE AREN'T SUPER, SUPER
TECHNICAL
POSITIONS THAT REQUIRE
THESE ARE MANY TIMES ENTRY LEVEL
CLASSIFIED POSITIONS.
AND IF THERE ARE LIKE A
CLASSROOM
AIDE WHO'S A TK AIDE,
WE SAY THERE HAS TO BE SOME
BASIC REQUIREMENTS.
NO ONE GETS TO SKIP AHEAD.
SO ALL THINGS BEING EQUAL, IF
THERE ARE,
IF THERE'S AN ENTRY LEVEL
POSITION THAT'S OPEN,
THAT ANYBODY IN THE PUBLIC CAN
QUALIFY
WITH MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS,
LET'S GIVE THE PERSON WHO'S
ALREADY ON
CAMPUS THE CRACK OF THAT JOB
SO THEY
CAN HAVE FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT
AND HAVE
A FULL TIME SALARY WITH
BENEFITS,
AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILY
AND BE LESS LIKELY TO LEAVE
AS WELL.
THEY MAY BE LESS LIKELY TO TO
BOLT AND GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE BECAUSE THEY'RE JUGGLING
PART TIME JOBS.
WE ALSO NARROWED THE TIME THE
WINDOW
FOR HAVING THESE POSITIONS OPEN,
SO WE DON'T HAVE UNFILLED
POSITIONS
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT ON
LOCAL,
UM LEAS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
SO I THINK WE'VE ANSWERED THE
CALL.
THESE ISSUES, MAYBE IT'S JUST
A POLICY CHOICE THAT, YOU KNOW,
THEY'D RATHER HAVE A BUNCH OF
PART TIME
PEOPLE AND HAVE THE RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT
FOR OUR,
OUR PUBLIC POSITIONS AND OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
UM, THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLE.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB
2088.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WILKE.
NO.
WILKE NO.
CORTEZ I CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 2 TO 1 ON
THAT BILL.
IT IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
SO WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
OUR FILE ITEMS IN ORDER.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
CONSENT.
BUT I NEED A MOTION.
I WILL MOVE THAT.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK COMMITTEE ASSISTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
WHICH INCLUDES FILE ITEMS ONE,
TWO, THREE AND EIGHT TODAY.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I SENATOR WILK.
I WILK.
I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
OKAY.
CONSENT HAS A VOTE OF 3 TO 0.
IT IS ON CALL.
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY.
COMMITTEE?
NO IT DIDN'T.
COMMITTEE.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR DURAZZO.
SENATOR.
LAIRD.
I REPORT ZERO ONE.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ON CALL.
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB 2068.
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ON FILE ITEM FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
I'LL MOVE.
I'LL MOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK, WE HAVE A MOTION.
ANY ASSISTANT, CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WILKE I WILKE I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
OKAY.
WE WILL LIFT THE CALL ON NUMBER
FIVE.
AND THAT IS AB 2088.
FOR FINAL ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CHAIR IS VOTING I.
THE VICE CHAIR IS VOTING NO.
SENATOR.
DURAZZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I.
OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 3 TO 1.
IT IS ON CALL.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX.
THAT'S AB 2284 ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I NEED A MOTION.
OH, DARN IT, WE NEED A MOTION.
DID WE GET ONE?
BUT THERE YOU GO, SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU.
ON, UH, FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX,
AB 2284.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS,
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATOR.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I, WILKE I, WILKE I
CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I FORD.
OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
IT'S ON CALL.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN.
AND WE NEED A MOTION ON.
SO MOVED BY WILK OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
OH.
UH, ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I WILK I WILK I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I 4 TO 0.
WE'RE ON CALL.
OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
WE'RE ON CALL.
UH, WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB, UH, 3190.
I THINK SENATOR CORTEZ HAD GIVEN
US A MOTION,
SO WE WILL NOW WAIT.
NO, WE DIDN'T HAVE A QUORUM WHEN
WE OFFERED.
OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A RE AUTHORED OFFERED
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT.
CALL THE ROLL.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WILK.
NO.
CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I.
DURAZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I.
3 TO 1.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A.
VOTE OF 3 TO 1 ON THAT BILL.
THAT ITEM IS ON CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN.
WE NEED A MOTION FOR AB 2421.
I LOVE IT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YOU'RE GOING TO DO ALL THE
MOTIONS ON.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2421.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I SENATOR.
WILKE I.
SENATOR.
CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I.
SENATOR.
DURAZO.
LAIRD I.
4 TO 0.
WE'RE ON CALL.
OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
IT IS ON CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 12.
OH, NO.
WE'RE ON 11 A B 2754.
WE NEED A MOTION.
THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTESE.
PLEASE CALL THE.
ROLL.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 11, AB 2754.
THE MOTIONS DO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE
ON THE JUDICIARY.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I WILK.
NO.
WILK.
CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I 3 TO 1.
WE'RE ON CALL.
AND THAT'S A BILL HAS A VOTE
OF 3 TO 1.
WE'RE ON CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12.
WE NEED A MOTION FOR AB 2889.
I'LL MOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR CORTESE, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ON AB 2889.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WILK.
NOT VOTING.
CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD.
LAIRD I.
3 TO 0.
OKAY, THAT BILL HAS.
A VOTE OF 3 TO 0.
IT IS ON CALL, AND WE'RE ON
FINAL ITEM NUMBER 13.
WE NEED A MOTION FOR AB 2975
MOVES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON.
FINAL ITEM 13.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH.
UH, SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WILK I WILK I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I DURAZO.
LAIRD I LAIRD I 4 TO 0.
WE'RE ON CALL.
OKAY.
THAT BILL HAS A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
IT IS ON CALL.
OKAY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
IS GOING
TO TAKE A LONG RECESS WHILE WE
WAIT FOR OUR OUR FELLOW MEMBER
TO PRESENT A NUMBER OF BILLS,
AND WE WILL RECONVENE WHEN SHE
ARRIVES.
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY, COMMITTEE IS IN SESSION.
WE ARE GOING TO REOPEN THE ROLL
AND BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHT.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I.
OKAY.
WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO 0, THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 2068.
ON THIS FILE ITEM.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
5 TO 0.
WE ARE OKAY WITH A VOTE OF 5
TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 2088
MCCARTY.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX,
AB 2284 ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, THE
MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO.
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
5 TO 0.
WITH A VOTE OF 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB 2335.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKENNA.
ON FILE NUMBER SEVEN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
SENATOR DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO I.
OKAY.
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH A VOTE
OF 5 TO 0.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 3190.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, THE
MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I.
THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATOR DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO I.
4 TO 1.
WE ARE OUT.
WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2421.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE.
ON FILE ITEM TEN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO I.
I'D LIKE TO SEE HER OUT OF HERE.
WITH THE VOTE OF 5 TO 0, THAT
BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
11,
AB 2754, ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON.
ON ITEM NUMBER 11.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1,
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
AND THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I 4 TO
1 WE ARE OUT OKAY.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 4 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER 12 AB
2889 ZEBRA.
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER 12.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0.
SENATOR WILK, SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I 4 TO 0.
WE'RE OUT WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
13.
THIS IS OUR FINAL ITEM AB 2975
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON.
ON FILE ITEM 13.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
OUR CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
5 TO 0.
WE ARE OUT.
WE HAVE A VOTE OF 5 TO 0 AND
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR FILE ITEMS
FOR THE DAY.
IF YOU WISH TO SUBMIT ANY
TESTIMONY,
FEEL FREE TO DO SO IN WRITING.
AND AT THE TIME OF 401, SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
IS ADJOURNED.